breaking news right now with new numbers
from the surge of migrants at the
southern border for the month of june
this fox news drone video shows between
400 and 500 migrants per drama
predominantly from venezuela and cuba
crossing into eagle pass texas on
wednesday of course it has become a
familiar sight streams of migrants in
groups of 10 20 30 hundredths from
mexico honduras guatemala and 100 plus
other countries piling into america's
wide open border every day and night
forcing the state of texas to step up
its efforts to defend the state and the
country including governor greg abbott's
executive order which authorizes the
texas national guard and the texas
department of public safety to return
apprehended migrants back to the border
on top of his launching of the 3 billion
border security mission known as
operation lone star the impact of this
wide open border from human trafficking
to death and illicit drug trafficking
has sparked a number of texas counties
to declare this literally an invasion of
america governor greg abbott joins me
right now governor it's good to see you
this morning thank you so much for being
here
my pleasure thank you maria
is this an invasion
listen uh the these counties are dealing
with something that's completely
unprecedented remember this it was just
two years ago we had the the lowest
number of uh people coming across the
border and apprehensions under president
trump uh and then president biden took
over and eliminated all of the policies
that president trump put in place and it
has led uh to this uh unprecedented
overwhelming number of people coming
across the border you gave some of the
numbers uh here's something more
important there's a record number of
people coming across the border from
more than
150 different countries across the
entire globe uh we're seeing over the
fourth of july for example uh
in just the del rio sector which is only
one of five sectors in the state of
texas there were about 5 000 people
either apprehended or or who were got a
ways but it gets worse maria because
look at the number of deaths that we're
dealing with you remember what happened
in the tractor trailer truck or where 53
people lost their lives listen things
like that happen all of the time so much
so that the united nations uh declared
the border between uh texas or the
united states and mexico uh to be the
the worst uh death border and most
dangerous border in the entire world
but on top of things like that we know
about 42 terrorists who have been
apprehended coming across the border
that's not counting the guidaways coming
across the border and then there's the
fentanyl coming across the border and so
yes
we we do have an invasion driven by the
cartels coming across our border that
are pouring people into our country at
unprecedented levels
it's absolutely extraordinary sir and i
know that the word invasion
comes with technical responses from the
government so are you reluctant to say
it's an invasion do you believe this is
an invasion
so the technical reasons for it lie in
the constitution uh there are two parts
of the u.s constitution article four
section 4 article 1 section 10 of the
constitution that use the word invasion
which is the reason why that is used in
that executive order that you said that
i
issued this past week i referenced both
of those plus
i referenced a provision of the texas
constitution that also uses the word
invasion the purpose of of using those
words is it triggers
certain additional ways and strategies
that states
can use their powers to try to protect
against actions such as this that are
driven by the cartels
okay i understand we have put up on the
screen ways that you and your team in
texas are defending the southern border
sir everything uh from obviously your
lone star
plan the operation lone star to
allocating resources deploying thousands
of national guard soldiers signing
new laws cracking down on human
trafficking and as you say the fentanyl
as well how do you expect the supreme
court's ruling that biden can end the
remaining mexico uh ruling to impact
border traffic and and what about title
42 do you think that's next after a
federal judge pretty much
put a put a temporary pause on it back
in may
so this is going to be a total disaster
first uh it was texas leading the way in
getting court decisions uh to
keep the remaining mexico policy and
keep the title 42 policy in place
obviously as you point out the supreme
court has stricken down
the remaining mexico policy uh let me
just give you the numbers that were
provided by the body administration they
they predicted that after the
elimination of these policies we should
have about 18 000 people coming across
the border illegally per day uh
extrapolate that for an annual basis
you're going to have more than six
million people coming across the border
a year to put this in context the
largest city in the state of texas is
houston we will have about one houston
coming across the border in texas every
year it took more than 100 years to
create houston now we will be adding in
houston every year this is outrageous
wow and there's a reason why americans
are so angry about the body
administration's approach to the border
yeah and and we see the implications
every day there was a report on fox news
last week about specific crimes
committed by illegal migrants and
so-called got aways i'm told that there
is at least 500 000 got aways and these
are the guideways that we know of that
we were seeing on surveillance camera
getting into the country is there
anything more you can do about this
governor we put a list of all of the
efforts that you've you you have been uh
making uh but there are still people who
say we need the governor of texas to do
more what more can you do about it so
let's go through and i haven't been able
to see what you put up on the screen but
let's go through the the things that
we're doing so we have a category called
turnbacks and we've turned back
tens of thousands of migrants who tried
to get across the border and we denied
them even coming across the border uh
once they cross the border we now have
two options one is uh to arrest them uh
and we we've made tens of thousands of
arrests uh for people and uh put them in
jail uh and and now we have this new
tool where we are now returning them to
the border all of these are completely
unprecedented no state in the history of
the united states of america has ever
done this and maria of course that's on
top of doing things like texas being the
only state in american history to build
our own border wall texas being the only
state in history uh where we have laid
down mile after mile after mile razor
wire
as barrier to prevent people from coming
in so texas is using every tool and
strategy that we can it is time now for
congress to step up under article 1
section 8 of the united states
constitution congress has the direct
authority to call for an invasion and to
do something about securing our border
it's time now for congress to stop
talking about it and step up and do
something about it
all right i want to get your take on uh
this investigation into texas border
security mission but first what is your
reaction to the president of mexico
lopez obrador endorsing your democrat
opponent beto o'rourke in the governor's
race this november obviously this is joe
biden's pick now you've got the
president of mexico uh endorsing beta
o'rourke
there's a reason for it and that is all
of these illegal immigrants coming from
mexico into texas they are allowed into
mexico by president uh lopez obrador and
they're coming from countries across the
entire world for one uh president lopez
obrador he could keep them out of mexico
if he wanted to but he does not want to
he wants to funnel them into the state
of texas maria can you imagine anything
worse in the united states of america
than than having lopez obrador working
with joe biden working with beto or work
those three with the open border
policies my fellow americans it would be
a disaster a crushing disaster from
which we may never recover uh if beto or
working hand-in-hand with joe biden and
the president of mexico on open border
policies in the state of texas it would
destroy our country
meanwhile instead of going to the border
and dealing with these issues president
biden's uh doj is investigating your
state and operation lone star
they're talking about potential civil
rights violations in uh that they
received indications that texas dps is
targeting certain individuals for arrest
on the basis of race and national origin
governor what is your response
maria you know i'm a former texas
supreme court justice as well as the
former texas attorney general everything
that we do
we make sure is consistent with state
and federal law this is nothing more
than a political attack by the byte
administration because byte
administration does not want us to try
to stop his open border policies and so
we are frustrating the about
administration's open border policies
and they're using any tool and strategy
they can to try to tamp down texas
efforts to enforce the immigration laws
and to secure our border
yeah and yet he won't visit the border
but he will visit saudi arabia in the
upcoming week he's trying to get the
saudis to put more oil on the market
even though texas is oil and gas rich
tell us about uh texas's potential to
produce enough oil to reduce pain at the
pump and and eliminate the need to go
hand in hand in saudi arabia
i mean it is so embarrassing and so
two-faced by the bible administration
going off to saudi arabia begging for
them to produce more oil when we have
the oil right here in the state of texas
texas is one of the if not the most
prolific producer of oil in the entire
world and all we need is uh the permits
from the buying administration the
authorization uh to build more
refineries uh we could be producing the
gasoline that would lower price of the
pump if the byte administration would
unleash
the american oil and gas ingenuity and
we could produce all the oil that we
need and get this as you probably know
president biden took oil from the
federal strategic oil reserves and
shipped it to other countries across the
globe as opposed to keeping it into the
united states and refining it here
turning into gasoline biden is one of
the reasons why we have such high
gasoline prices
well that's right and we are going to be
talking about the fact that some of that
oil actually went to china our largest
adversary real quick before you go all
of this is not falling on deaf ears we
just saw representative maida flores uh
flip a seat in an 84 hispanic district
in texas do you believe this is going to
see
we'll see more of this going into the
november elections and will we see the
border states
voters react
this will be a massive
right this is going to be a massive red
wave along the border the border
counties and the border districts have
historically always been democrat uh the
one that myra foreign won was always
held by a democrat is now held by a
republican we will see other republican
victories along the border i will do
extraordinarily well on the border it's
because so many people on the border are
so angry about the blind
administration's approach to the open
border policies and they're going to be
voting against the bite administration
voting for republicans who they know
it's going to be the republicans who are
stepping up securing our border
all right governor good to have you this
morning thanks very much for your
efforts we'll keep following it texas
governor greg abbott this morning in
texas thank you